what's up guys my name is curly and you
might not know that i'm actually super
afraid of water
and that includes rain puddles rivers
oceans lakes but today
we're going to conquer that fear
hola mi gente it's ivan and today we're
here at the lake and i'm gonna be
helping curly confront his fear of
water by going fishing yvonne
yes here we are we are
in what is this place it's we're at a
lake right now
great my favorite way to go fishing i'm
ready to fish i brought some stuff so
you brought stuff out yes
[Music]
i brought this beautiful fish what is
that
[Music]
it's to entice the fish to come out it's
a flirtation
device i'm going to woo the fish out of
the ocean
what else you brought okay cologne
it's fish pheromone
who doesn't like the smell of fish am i
right we smell like bait
i like smells and i figured fish like
snows too yeah
okay we we might just leave that out for
sure
bueno curly i'm going to teach you how
to bait a hook beautiful okay are you
excited are you ready i don't know what
that means but yes i am super excited
basically we're gonna put some worms on
the hook so that the fish can try to eat
them okay but we're gonna use
fake worms for now because we're saving
the real worms for later
okay basically what you want to do is
you're gonna poke
the worm through the hook
so basically you're going to go right
towards the center there you go
and then you're going to put it like
halfway yes
i made just something special little
fish made you a little meal there little
fish
let's face your fears let's go
curly let's go and you already know
that if i'm gonna go fishing i gotta
look good
[Music]
so i guess i will now place myself into
this you gotta place yourself into this
okay
[Music]
okay really sit yeah and then i go in
yeah that's right that's right we did it
yep we got our life's vest over here
[Music]
what are you doing
okay bring him back oh okay you bring
him back like that
are you sure you don't want me to do it
i need to sit there so let's change
it
oh my god i am
it's time to bait our hooks yes yes are
you ready is the question yeah i want
you to show me now oh man
all right you did it here we go go for
it
oh that was a nice one i'll go one two
three
[Music]
fishes in the ocean
here we are oh you got something
oh i felt it it was oof you know what
i am having a good time actually it's
kind of meditative right
like it's very like serene and peaceful
out here just being on the water
all right yvonne don't wait up i'll be
right back
[Music]
what did you see it's too hard to
explain it
i think fishing is a sport that is meant
to be
enjoyed with company it can be a long
waiting game
so you're gonna need some good
conversations yeah also like you have to
be prepared it's kind of like dating in
l.a like you think you caught one
and you're like like this like you're
like
[Music]
and they took the word you paid for the
dinner just like my love life
they just take the worm and go
[Music]
all right so i did my share and now i'm
enjoying the view while curly is roaming
the boat
look at this sunset i know it's
beautiful wow it's been a beautiful day
today i had a lot of fun out there it
was so good we were cracking up
the whole time you definitely don't need
to catch a fish
to have fun fishing it's all about
living in the moment
and creating memories i would seriously
recommend it to all of my city friends
because it's just like
trust me it's a it's a mess it's a gag
it's so much fun
we're gonna crack up the whole time like
let's just go
[Music]